comme une marche vers un travail choisi
est stable le camping-car de l'emploi
c'est un bureau d'entretien d'embauché
qui se déplace au coeur des quartiers
dits prioritaires
j'habite à vesoul je suis bénévole aux
restos du coeur et présidente de
l'association tous ensemble aux jeunes
de vesoul j'ai enchaîné les petits
boulots
mauvais valablement j'étais hôtesse
d'accueil j'étais femme de chambre ce
sonic youth demi après son bac b team
une scène meyer a eu de graves problèmes
de santé qui l'ont empêché de travailler
pendant dix ans depuis mars dernier la
jeune femme est à compagnie pour qu'elle
puisse exercer le métier qu'elle a
choisi chargé d'accueil
face à elle son futur employeur lui
assure un premier poste chez habitat 70
je pense les gens partent et ils verront
moins postuler à des postes de cadre de
deux directeurs jose comme ça mais faut
pas se mettre
c'est déjà assez compliqué comme ça sans
se mettre des phrases soi même quand je
pense un jeune qui vit dans un quartier
dit prioritaire à cinq fois moins de
chance pour décrocher un entretien
d'embauché que s'il venait d'ailleurs
pour déjouer les statistiques une
dizaine de jeunes femmes bénéficient de
cet accompagnement financé par l'état et
la ville de vesoul
quand on arrive avec un camping car s'il
est suffisamment visible pour attirer le
public invisible donc les personnes nous
pose des questions on disons camping-car
de l'emploi qu'est ce que c'est ça sert
à quoi etc et on a pu repérer comme ça
des femmes qui n'étaient pas inscrits ni
pôle emploi ni à la mission locale
c'est le moment du bilan de mi-parcours
élus et représentants de l'état sont
venus encourager les jeunes femmes il
faut sortir de cette posture de jeu
subit quelque chose j'ai inverse le rôle
je multiplie les entretiens et c'est moi
betty avec mes qualités avec ma
personnalité avec secteur très généreux
qui se retrouvent en situation de
choisir en fonction de mes appétence
vivre dans un quartier prioritaire peut
ainsi devenir un atout face à un
employeur pour une embauche en cdi un
patron peut toucher jusqu'à dix sept
mille euros sur trois ans paraît tout à
l'heure des emplois francs je trouve que
c'est une très bonne idée de l'inscrire
de même parce que les employeurs ne le
savent pas ils peuvent bénéficier des
emplois francs mettez le sur cd ce
banquier a accompagné dès le départ ce
dispositif
son entreprise a signé le programme
national pacte pour sortir de
l'exclusion les habitants des banlieues
outre ses conseils le directeur
ries tauriel va aussi proposer à allier
de fou dit une licence pro en alternance
c'est très bien d'être aidé enfin moi le
dispositif c'est madame cette fois qui
travaille à la mission locale qui m'a
mis dessus sinon je connaissais pas du
tout avant et puis bah grâce à ben je
vais réussir peut-être avoir une
alternance c'est important qu'on vient
vers ces jeunes parce que si je ne
vienne pas à nous ils n'osent pas venir
vers les grandes enseignes les
entreprises il est important qu'on
puisse les aider
est-ce que ici il ya des talents et des
talents il faut les faire émerger le
travail est bel et bien la pierre
angulaire de l'insertion
depuis deux ans le camping cars de
l'emploi a soutenu 65 stagiaires en
haute-saône 95% de la première promotion
ont un contrat